[Musique]
le département de La Réunion a fait du
bien-être des personnes âgées un des
axes forts de sa politique d'action
sociale ainsi la collectivité
représentée par sévices présidentes
terrestres et Augustine Romano étaient
présentes ce samedi 25 mars à la Ravine
des Cabris à Saint-Pierre pour
l'inauguration d'une maison
d'accueillant familiaux la MAAF ami
cette nouvelle structure est la première
du genre dans le sud de Lille et propose
une alternative aux maisons de retraite
conventionnelle le département est
présent aujourd'hui peut cette première
inauguration de la MAAF ami dans le sud
tout simplement parce qu'il accompagne
ce genre de structure les personnes
âgées font partie de l'une de nos
priorités au niveau taxo social au
niveau du département il en porte aussi
des financements au niveau de cette
création de marque c'est assez très les
gens justement à faire ce genre de
marque parce que on dirait que c'est on
est à la maison cet établissement pour
senior à semaines dont la livraison
s'est faite début 2023 a pu bénéficier
de l'accompagnement et du soutien
financier du Département c'est une MAAF
qu'on a initié il y a deux ans avec
l'accompagnement du conseil
départemental donc pour initier cette
MAAF on a obtenu subvention de l'ordre
de 250000 euros avec 150000 euros pour
le l'investissement et 100000 euros pour
le fonctionnement c'est ce qui nous a
permis en fait d'initier ces travaux et
après justement la concrétisation de
tout ce volet en amont on ouvre la MAAF
début avril 2023 avec donc six
pensionnaires qui vont rejoindre si ils
accueillis qui vont rejoindre notre
maison pour 5 accueillants familiaux qui
ont également été formés par le biais de
dispositifs mis en place par le Conseil
Général donc c'est une structure qui
fait sur l'ensemble à peu près 250
mètres carrés et chaque résident aura sa
chambre et son espace privatif et puis
il y aura également des lieux de
rencontres de partage à travers la salle
d'activité la cuisine les espaces
extérieurs donc on a vraiment lancer ce
projet dans la même continuité que tu
dispositif qui a été initié par le
conseil général c'est à dire un
environnement qui reste professionnel
qui reste normé mais qui offre tout le
confort en fait du cocon familial
destiné davantage au Seigneur autonome
la MAAF ami accueillera ses premiers
résidents le 3 avril prochain certains
d'entre eux comme Thérèse ont profité de
cette journée pour commencer à prendre
leur marque dans la maison je suis très
content c'est bien on se sent en famille
on se sent chez soi on se sent
on a on a certaines
[Musique]
moi c'est comme si j'étais chez moi là
vous voyez mais seulement je suis
contente parce qu'il y aura des amis on
pourra discuter on pourra jouer un cadre
de vie rassurant et une présence en
continu des accueillants familiaux voilà
qui fait déjà de cet établissement une
réussite puisqu'il affiche déjà complet
[Musique]